doing the right thing is always the
right thing always and forever hey blog
this will be a good one late Sunday
night very rare for me to leave the
family but this is a good cause
obviously the devastation puerto rico my
family spent a lot of time there do a
lot of business done business with a lot
of people from there and ate on here the
owner of hunting fish club we've seen in
you in different logs haven't been here
much lately but you've seen him in other
vlogs very friendly with Jorge Posada
and asked me to be a major player and so
I decided co-host step up gonna be a lot
of Bainer people tonight that'd be fun
to interview some of them Dirac and just
really anytime you can do something for
a worthwhile cause like as you guys know
I don't tend to show a lot of my charity
water a pencil promise work or a lot of
the other stuff I do in the nonprofit
world I kind of grew up in a I have a
cynical point of view of it cuz so many
my friends leverage it to show that
they're a good person but it is a
passionate part of my life and so you
know I thought it'd be important you
know as I'm talking about you things and
showing you guys different things like I
do feel a sense of responsibility of
showing this part as well just a little
bit still won't push it I'm much more
comfortable slinging my books and my
sneakers then kind of like the stuff I'm
more proud of you know like you guys
know a lot of this stuff but anyway
nonetheless fun stuff looking forward to
it
buncha athletes in the building bunch of
vaynermedia employees in the building
that's a win-win situation just just
lost to Tampa Bay so I'm a little bit
bummed that pretty much officially wraps
up their season now you know but uh but
a great trip obviously as you guys know
this is two days before the sneaker
launches probably air right after it so
I just want to
I'll just preempt it though a little
future here I want to thank everybody
who supported me on that and wish me a
40-second happy birthday and hopefully
Barack will get some rad rad context
babban coming to he's heading hopefully
uh durock will capture some rad content
[Music]
patients would probably be the biggest
thing that I would tell them yeah sure
mom and dad want him to do well and he
wants to be well and like the reality is
he's a kid he's a [ __ ] kid 22 is a
[ __ ] kid
you know like it's hard when you're the
parent right because you want him to be
settled in a good place and you love him
right
22 is a kid the cliche thing like a mom
of a 22 year old is worried about it's
dramatically less of an issue than I
think you would realize he could do both
of those boys could do nothing right 230
nothing and still be kids the way I see
the world there's so much opportunity
because the world is completely
misunderstanding what's actually
happening
like the entire world trades on Facebook
Instagram and YouTube and then it feeds
to everything else it's it's all
happening in here this is the world
there is nothing else just to see Syd
looking so sharp this is worth the
entire price tag real good other than
the Jets my life is awesome you win and
then everything else works out you know
you guys hustling you got businesses
going on what kind of business would you
do
give me a baseball player okay who's
your favorite player
Aaron judge makes sense what kind of
business would you have
musician like who's your favorite
musician Green Day that's a good [ __ ]
answer my man
I like that saying I love that you guys
having fun
awesome
[Music]
got to tell the youth that being a
baseball player and a musician is not
running a business let's play a little
up on the blog let's do a little ABC all
right blog in the comments do you prefer
a B or C I'm gonna put on some [ __ ] KD I
got you double nickels 550 I'm bidding
up on the little KD Jersey you know
really yeah he's a good entrepreneur
he's a nice basketball player but he's a
good entrepreneur big shout-out to
draymond Green one of my favorites fun
fact I put Fremont on snapchat
like I always say like you don't need to
buy my sneakers and books you do you
I'm here to force you to do you hey
Dooley rough really well do not there is
no try
traipse rocks crates great don't worry
Jordans you well thanks for coming
I'm excited about tonight we've raised a
lot of money there's something I'd love
to say and I say it a lot which is doing
the right thing is always the right
thing it's super simple but I think more
than ever the people that are fortunate
enough whether it's financial whether
it's there's a lot of people walking
around here that have a tension of
others because of the thing I'm
passionate about social media and things
of that nature platforms I see a lot of
you know amazing athletes and incredible
entrepreneurs and business people I
think more than ever we need to be
thoughtful about putting our energy and
I'm a very optimistic positive kind of
dude and I think there's a lot going on
in the world and I think look all of us
want to do things that are the right
thing and you want to do things that are
authentic to you and so for me for me
visiting the you know Puerto Rico so
many times from a family standpoint and
doing business with so many
entrepreneurs there it was super easy
obviously when you text me if you told
me how to go to Iowa and milk a cow I
would do it but for me it's a little
more interesting when when it's a little
bit closer and deeper to my heart it's
also super fun for me tonight
specifically because so many of the
people from vaynermedia are here and I
want to send a huge shout out to all of
them because I love them so much and
[Applause]
look you know I'm just humbled to be
here I appreciate even
and I appreciate the generosity from
everybody downstairs on the silent
auction and I know we have a live
auction and it just means a lot for you
guys to be our Sunday nights are not the
most convenient two weeks notice is not
the most convenient and just seeing so
many people go out of their way to be
here tonight means a lot to all of us so
thank you so much we have brought more
than 200 patients that needed critical
treatment to the u.s. these spaces
needed chemotherapy and you thought
Ellis's they needed respirators that you
we've taken supplies I need more than 13
lights of what Rico
but now there's still a need to and this
is the process that's gonna take a long
time we need to clean up with rebuilding
and we need to build buttery toast
economy back up and that's what we're
gonna do with the funds that all of you
have graciously donated to me I'm going
to continue to do that until were Drita
comes back stronger than ever
[Music]
thank you so much raise a lot of money
tonight I'm really really amazed right
if you do stick to midnight Gary is
going to milk and Omaha I'm thrilled to
be like business but what giving giving
is giving you don't need the appellation
and people and people blender too
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
got your chest bump
inspired guys a [ __ ] hustler that's
why I'm trying to leave like that I'm
[ __ ] working 24/7 trying to make it
happen right okay good time tonight
doing the right thing the right thing
yes it's true d-roc doing the right
thing is always the right thing
always and forever like
[Music]